[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
baseball les cougars de montigny le
bretonneux des buts par saison par deux
victoires à domicile pour leur retour en
première division lésigny montant dominé
clermont ferrand dans leur stade jean
maréchal plus de détails a su dans ce
magazine gymnastique le club d'elancourt
maurepas organisait ce week-end les demi
finales des championnats de france au
palais des sports des encours
cette compétition a attiré plus de 300
gymnastes de la région retour sur cet
événement assure le nouveau praticable
du club cyclisme
françois pervis six fois champion du
monde et médaillé de bronze à rio l'été
dernier de retour en équipe de france
ils montrent un participera notamment
championnat du monde aaron compte du 12
au 16 avril
le sportif de 32 ans va s'aligner sur la
vitesse individuelle le keirin km la
vitesse par équipes nous lui avons posée
à trois questions
gros plan à présent sur les principaux
résultats du week end dans le
département
[Musique]
on commence donc ce magazine par du
baseball c'était leur objectif et ils
l'ont fait les cougars de montigny le
bretonneux débutent leur saison par deux
victoires à domicile pour leur retour en
première division les imans temps dominé
les arvernes de clermont ferrand une
victoire qui les propulse à la première
place du classement du championnat même
chanta montagneux je signe et accusé les
jeunes ont un début de saison parfait
pour montigny le bretonneux les cougars
promu cette année en 1re division
longtemps porté ce dimanche 2 avril sur
la fin contre les arvernes de clermont
ferrand le score 6-0 dans le premier
match et 3 2 dans le second d'
excellentes très bonne journée
c'était le but c'était d'entrée de
réussir notre entrée dans ce championnat
et on l'a fait on a fait de très belle
façon
on l'a fait avec des lanceurs qui ont
tout donné qui ont fait vraiment le job
sur le monticule
c'est ce que j'attendais c'est ce que
j'attendais aujourd'hui vraiment de
cette journée et voilà ça c'est ça s'est
réalisé ça et c'est génial on était tous
motivés tous dans l'esprit d'équipé on
sait tous motivés
on est tous solidaires c'est ce qui a
fait qu'on a qu'on a pu gagner avec ces
deux victoires les cougars de montigny
le bretonneux son retour en tête de
première division avec 100% de victoires
les objectif pourrait être revu à la
hausse les objectifs mais voilà ils sont
ils sont l'essence qui sont ces aléas
les prendre le allait se mettre ceux
classés dans le haut de tableau
[Applaudissements]
on a parlé de maintien on a parlé de 5e
6e place je pense qu'aujourd'hui on peut
on peut aller grimper on peut on peut
monter se placer en haut de tableau on
peut aller faire les play-offs
allez comme je dis chatouiller les
grosses écuries les grosses équipes qui
sont là depuis des années on peut le
faire on peut vraiment le faire le
prochain match va arriver vite les
cougars se déplaceront ce dimanche 9
avril sur le terrain de rouen baseball
76 l'équipe qui a soulevé dix titres de
champion de france dans son histoire et
qui a remporté ses deux premiers matches
lors de cette première journée
armand a créé une fois n'est pas coutume
nous allons parler de gymnastique dans
ce set 8 sport les puristes ont pu
assister à une compétition d'envergure
au palais des sports d'elancourt le club
de la gemme a organisé les demi finales
des championnats de france dans la
structure plus de 300 gymnastes venus de
toute l'ile-de-france âgés de 10 à 30
ans étaient présents pour ce rendez vous
on écoute la vice-présidente du club
morgan poulard une compétition la zone
du fameux doublé de meknès jamais à
transgresser une bonne compétition à
faire au palais des sports
c'est un week-end important surtout
puisque c'est l'objectif c'est de
qualité de ginette au championnat de
france donc c'est un des deux plus gros
week-end de notre saison le club de
gymnastique de la gemme a remporté
pendant la compétition trois médailles
d'or une médaille d'argent et deux
médailles de bronze
à cette occasion le club de gymnastique
d'elancourt mort pas à présenter au
public son nouveau praticable ce dernier
a été utilisé lors des derniers jeux
olympiques de rio par les super stars de
la discipline
il permettra aux athlètes du club
d'avoir un meilleur robots et de
réaliser des figures plus complexes le
praticable sera surtout moins
traumatisant pour les articulations
la vice-présidente entre le vice
président en charge du sport à saint
quentin en yvelines jean piat recevait 7
et au micro de nicolas dont 20 pour le
club de gymnastique la participation
bien sûr et très importante des deux
communes
mais l'agglomération tient à apporter un
soutien important au niveau représente
le club de gymnastique d'elancourt
maurepas et notamment dans cet
investissement de praticable à hauteur
de 8000 euros ce qui représente tout de
même près du tiers du prix d'achat du
praticable on prend présent la direction
du centre aquatique de saint cyr l'école
en records d'apnée est tombée ce samedi
dans la structure le fonds aux cubains
on dit cabreira avila a parcouru pendant
une heure 150 5 longueurs de bassin de
25 m en monopalme sous l'eau soit une
distance totale de
3 km et 892 mètres il bat de 26
longueurs le précédent record de pascal
mazet établi en janvier dernier cette
performance a été réalisée pour soutenir
les enfants autistes on écoute le record
man andy cabreira avila on pense va bien
m'aider c'est alain fort parce que si on
menace trop vite on risque de grimper
c'est très émouvant parce qu'elle est
chaque longueur et différentes
conceptions trop techniques sur les palm
âge et surtout des parcs solaires et
peut pas être essoufflée et les parois
des primes des craintes mais je nage
avec tous les personnes que j'aime dans
mon coeur est encore grand bravo à andy
cabreira avila un mot de la ryder cup
2018 la plus grande compétition de golf
au monde à organiser du 28 au 30
septembre golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines pour pouvoir accueillir plus
de 200000 spectateurs sur les trois
jours de compétition des équipes de
l'european tour les organisateurs du
tournoi sont sur place pour réfléchir à
la logistique pendant l'événement on
écoute le responsable de la ryder cup
2018 au micro de nicolas d'emblée nous
sommes engagés avec toutes les autorités
dans un plan de transport qui est un
élément clé dans la ryder cup
nous essayons vraiment de permettre aux
gens de venir en train à la ryder cup
nous travaillons aussi sur plusieurs
détails notamment les infrastructures
autour du site pour l'hébergement et
tous les outils pour les télévisions qui
sont des éléments importants pour la
ryder cup
et ça marche chez ibm une centaine de
personnes travaillent ici pour le succès
de cet événement on passe au ballon
ovale mauvaise opération pour le club de
rugby de plaisir les plaisirs oise sont
inclinés 35 à 20 sur le terrain de ris
orangis dans ce choc entre le premier et
le deuxième de fédérale 2 au classement
plaisir perd la tête se retrouve
deuxième à quatre points de son
adversaire du jour et sera donc
deuxièmes de cette saison régulière
avant de jouer à les play-offs de fin de
saison
on continue à parler de rugby la
rugbywomen jade le pesq joueuses du
quinze de france étaient mercredi
dernier au stade de porchefontaine alors
rendu visite au club de versailles les
enfants ont pu échanger quelques mots et
quelques balles avec elle un reportage
de camille lambert
jacques demers inondé de fleurs en
accueil de star pour cette joueuse de
rugby féminin mercredi 29 mars le club
de versailles a eu la chance de recevoir
l'arrière du quinze de france
jade le pesq non la fin match mittal et
avec les bleus et mi-temps avec les
verts on l'a fait dévier du sud où cinq
victimes un rapport arrive du rugby la
jeune sportive de 24 ans a passé l'après
midi avec les enfants de la section des
moins de 7 ans un moment de partage mais
aussi pour promouvoir le rugby féminin
le rugby c'est avant tout un sport où on
voit là c'est comme une deuxième famille
on joue avec les copains et les copines
et c'est vrai que c'est de se retrouver
ce sport d'équipé qui permet de mettre
en valeur tout le monde que ce soit les
plus costauds les plus maigres mais les
plus rapides et on a besoin de tout le
monde sur un terrain de rugby et c'est
ce qui fait la beauté de ce sport tu on
l'a maintenant une dizaine de filles et
4,5 femme qui joue dans le club et on
espère développer et donc la venue de
schalke pesc qui a quand même un
palmarès puisque est un événement
intéressant de communication et même de
promotion du de la femme vis-à-vis du
rugby et à versailles une venue
organiser grâce au lien de parenté avec
l'un des enfants un lien qui sera
peut-être encore plus fort avec le club
jade lepez pourra en devenir la marraine
les jeunes attendent déjà son retour
avec impatience
sur ses cuisses mme le nouveau président
de la fédération française michel
laquelle l'eau était jeudi dernier
devant la presse au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'homme a intronisé à la mi mars pour
succéder à david lappartient était
accompagné à cette occasion des
anciennes gloires française de la piste
arnaud tournant et florian rousseau l'a
détaillé à cette occasion les grands
traits de sa politique sportive sur les
prochaines années
on écoute michel callot c'est d'abord
une grande fierté c'est en même temps
que la fierté une grande responsabilité
de pouvoir piloter finalement à la
destinée de son sport quand on est
passionné de cyclisme
forcément on a envie d'orienter d'une
certaine manière l'avenir de son sport
en france je suis très conscient de la
lourdeur de la tâche qui m'attend mais
en même temps je suis vraiment déterminé
à ce que ce mandat permet à la
fédération de se moderniser de
progresser sur tous les terrains et
triompher sur le plan sportif on reste
dans le monde du cyclisme le pistard de
l'équipe de france françois pervis six
fois champion du monde va s'envoler pour
hong kong pour disputer les championnats
du monde du 12 au 16 avril
ils montrent un qui s'entraîne presque
tous les jours sur la piste du vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines a de
grosses ambitions pour cette compétition
nous lui avons posée à trois questions
mes objectifs pour le premier rang on
commence par la vitesse par équipes donc
la vitesse par équipes avec l'équipe on
sait pas trop encore où est ce qu'on
situe par rapport au niveau
international donc on espère quand même
faire une belle médaille de bronze
faire troisième ce serait très bien je
pense que les deux premières
les deux premières places sur cette
épreuve là ça sera pas pas jouable pour
nous s'il ya vraiment des très gros très
gros équipe est favorite et donc nous
troisième on serait super content pour
ça
ensuite moi en individuel il ya le
caring le caring dont j'ai été champion
du monde plusieurs fois donc j'aimerais
retrouver ce titre que j'apprécie tant
parce que c'est vraiment une épreuve que
j'apprécie donc un podium en kering voir
le titre si si tout se passe bien
ensuite il ya la vitesse individuelle la
vitesse individuelle je suis un petit
peu moins on va dire je manque un peu
d'explosivité donc la vitesse
individuelle c'est vraiment une épreuve
où beaucoup d'explosivité donc là je
pense que je serai un petit peu moins
bien
donc j'ai plage est pas vraiment
d'objectif à part aller le plus loin
possible dans le tournoi ont fini par le
kilomètre le kilomètre
j'étais aussi plusieurs fois champion du
monde dans ces disciplines l'a donc
j'aimerais bien retrouver aussi mon
titre de champion du monde des
kilomètres donc
le podium je pense que podium est
jouable mais il ya quand même un gros
favoris soit km hollandais theo bos et
donc je pense que
ça va être très difficile de le battre
mais en tout cas si je peux faire un
podium en kering en vitesse par équipes
et au kilomètre
ce sera déjà un très bon très bon
résultat d'ensemble
c'est vrai que maintenant je fais partie
des meubles comme on dit je suis le plus
ancien de l'équipe de france depuis déjà
quelques années maintenant il ya une
nouvelle génération qui arrive après les
jeux de rio il ya des très très jeune il
ya même une fille qui n'est pas encore
majeur donc qui ont forcément pas mon
expérience donc moi c'est à moi de le
rapporter les petites ficelles du métier
leur donner des conseils pour éviter les
très grosses erreurs après c'est
important qu'ils apprennent de même
qu'ils suivent pas exactement un mot
pour mot ce que je leur dis où le chemin
que moi j'ai pris il faut qu'ils
trouvent leur propre chemin leur propre
façon de faire et ça c'est vraiment
important donc je donne des conseils
mais je ne leur impose pas des choses
donc c'est vrai qu'on a déjà couru
ensemble il ya un mois et demi en coupe
du monde
ils sont venus me voir les gelées très
très jeunes sont venus me voir et m'ont
posé beaucoup de questions moi ça m'a
fait plaisir parce que en quelque sorte
c'est que bah ils ont ils ont confiance
en ce que je peux leur répondre et ils
prennent ça en compte donc c'est à des
plaisirs de l'est de les aider de les
aiguiller et puis de les conseiller et
c'est vrai que là bas ça c'est on va
dire que c'est un pas une passation
power parce que je pense que je suis
encore je suis encore apte à à gagner
des titres et des médailles mais en tout
cas c'est un nouveau rôle
un nouveau rôle pour moi c'est la fin de
ce statut de sport merci d'avoir suivi
très belle soirée sur tv fil 78
[Musique]